welcome to had any day two of the
scandal that is now rocking the entire
world of higher education
dozens of wealthy families business
executives and yes Hollywood celebrities
caught rigging the system paying huge
bribes fixing even SAT at a CT scores
also their little children their
precious kids could gain admission into
some of America's top universities now
the man at the very center of this fraud
is named William Rick singer he is
cooperating with federal authorities
apparently naming names hours ago Full
House actress Lori Loughlin appeared in
court to face charges for her
involvement in this scheme and was
released get this on a 1 million dollar
bond by the way the same amount is
r.kelly and she and her husband are
accused of paying half a million dollars
so that the two daughters could get into
USC as purported crew athletes they
never were crew rowers ever I never
played once and they even went as far as
to photoshop pictures now fellow actress
Felicity Huffman was arrested at
gunpoint during a raid by multiple FBI
agents after she was accused of paying
thousands of dollars to fake her
daughter's SAT scores and according to
the university of southern california
students who benefited from this fraud
may now get kicked out of the college
but that should be the least of their
worries because their parents now
apparently they will be facing up to 20
years behind bars so far 50 people have
been charged including multiple college
athletic Coaches a school administrator
several SAT AC T officials and fraudster
William Rick singer claims to have
successfully serviced over 800 clients
who paid him tens and tens of thousands
and in some cases millions of dollars
unbelievable why I guess for status
bragging rights so that they could tell
their friends that their privileged
children got into the best schools even
though in reality their children weren't
good enough academically or weren't good
enough athletically to do so they
stomped on the futures of other people
this is a zero-sum game there's only so
many spots in each school children will
probably not as financially well-off or
kid
who had to work for everything kids who
put in the time academically or
athletically talking about thousands and
thousands of hours studying training and
actually earning their grades or a
position in their sport kids who spent
all this time on and off the field to
better themselves and enrich the school
with their incredible athletic ability
kids who played sports competitively
most kids now they focus on one sport
since about the time they're seven now I
know because I've lived through it now
if found guilty those involved in the
scandal are the new faces of yes greed
corruption and selfishness in a rare
moment of honesty even fake news CNN's
Don Lemon summed it up like this take a
look this is an America that can be
deeply unfair where hard work doesn't
necessarily pay off where if you have
money you can buy anything because just
about everything is for sale including
integrity for sale where a whole lot of
people have real good reason to believe
the system is rigged against them listen
this is what Donald Trump tapped into in
a lot of ways guess what he was right
all right thankfully 2020 Democratic
hopeful were very very excited about
this night lifelong fraudster herself
Elizabeth Warren she's weighing in on
this controversy because at this time or
a time like this
Warren is exactly the moral compass
America needs take a look as a parent
how much sympathy would you have for
these parents who are embroiled in this
alleged cheating scandal zero zero okay
well the same Elizabeth Warren she lied
on her Texas bar registration probably
lied most to most of her employers and
higher education
Harvard telling them she was a Native
American literally faking what her race
and background was to gain an advantage
senator Warren the poster child for
fraud and higher education and by the
way she's not the only 20/20 Democrat
facing claims of rampant hypocrisy in
tonight's 20/20 Hannity watch on the
election while we have breaking news
tonight remember when the left told
America that all claims of sexual
conduct there to be believed no due
process no presumption of innocence
necessary
apparently Democrats don't apply that
same standard to themselves as we have
learned tonight a former aide to me to
champion senator Kirsten Gillibrand from
New York actually resigned after her
claims of sexual misconduct were
allegedly swept under the rug and
meanwhile Bernie Sanders 2016 campaign
is still dealing with allegations of
sexual harassment apparently believe all
women is not a motto for the Sanders
campaign it's not one they ever obeyed
themselves and don't forget Kamala
Harris one of her top aides forced to
resign because of sexual misconduct but
only after details of his $400,000 pay
off became public brave senators and
this will be an issue in 2020 we'll have
more on this later in the show but we
turn now to a serious situation over
America's skies tonight out of an
abundance of caution earlier today the
president ordered all Boeing 737 max 8/9
planes grounded in light of new
information from the ongoing
investigation into the crash of
Ethiopian Airlines flight 302 let's take
a look
we're going to be issuing an emergency
order of prohibition to ground all
flights of the 737 max eight and the 737
max nine airlines have been all notified
airlines are agreeing with this the
safety of the American people in all
people is our paramount concern Boeing
is an incredible company they are
working very very hard right now and
hopefully they'll very quickly come up
with the answer but until they do the
planes are grounded president is making
the right move tonight his number one
priority has always been protecting
human life he's pro-life look what he's
trying to do with the border protect
American citizens four thousand
homicides 30,000 sexual assaults in two
years and a hundred thousand violent
assaults by illegal immigrants against
Americans let me be more clear I want to
say this about Boeing Boeing is
great American company they have created
some of the best most reliable planes
used worldwide I want you I want Boeing
to beat the French own Airbus in the
open market and I know they will all
Americans should be rooting for Boeing
to get to the bottom of this serious
situation resolve it and get back to
producing some of the best aircraft this
world has ever seen and some of our
fellow American citizens they build
those aircraft we're going to bring you
those developments as they continue to
unfold first we turn to our Hannity
watch on the deep state we have more
breaking news tonight for the past few
nights right here on this program we
have been urging you to just hang on be
patient because justice is around the
corner for all high-level government
bureaucrats but we have been telling you
about for two years those that were
involved in rigging Clinton's
investigations so she can remain the
Democratic candidate those involved in
trying to alter and impact an election
with what Russian lies they knew were
lies but they disseminated them anyway
all while persecuting the Trump campaign
for something he never did or his
campaign never did tonight all that
congressman Devin Nunez give you a
preview of these coming attractions take
a look we continue to work at on the
House Intelligence Committee we will be
making several criminal referrals and we
hope that the Justice Department will
take these up when is actually forward
on them when are those criminal
referrals going to be made
I would guess sometime in the next 2 3 4
weeks we can see we would like to see
what's in the molar report my sources
telling me tonight this will only be the
tip of the iceberg what is going to be
happening in coming weeks will be major
it should be major and there will be
more after that it's not just coming
from senator Nunez Senator Lindsey
Graham who will join us in a minute he
now has reopened the Senate
investigation into the FISA abuse
scandal and remember we still have the
inspector general's report we are
waiting for as it relates to inspector
general Horowitz Senator Graham as I
said will be here in a moment and also
thanks to the courage of congressman
Collins of Georgia the full transcript
of the lease of page test
the mone we now learned yesterday and
learning more today that it was Obama's
Department of Justice actually directing
the FBI not to charge Hillary Clinton
with the standard in the law which was
gross negligence according to Lisa Paige
quote we had multiple conversations with
the Justice Department about charging
gross negligence and the Justice
Department's assessment was that it was
both constitutionally vague really so
that they did not actually feel they
could permissibly bring that charge and
they needed a new standard congressman
Ratcliffe then asked quote you're making
it sound like it was the department that
told you you're not going to charge
gross negligence which is in the statute
because the prosecutors were telling you
we're not going to page respondent that
is correct that's correct that means
this was ordered by the Department of
Justice of Barack Obama headed by
Loretta Lynch yes the same Attorney
General at the time that met stays
before this decision secretly on a
tarmac in Phoenix with Bill Clinton
supposedly 45 minutes talking about
grandchildren this was in the final days
of that investigation the same person
who asked James Comey don't call this an
investigation we call it a matter really
that was an investigation should have
been the same person who reports
directly to Barack Obama tonight we now
add a very important new component to
this entire deep state issue
what did Barack Hussein Obama know and
when did he know it this now takes it
straight to the former president and the
Oval Office Barack Obama and thanks to
Paige we also know the top FBI
investigator or boyfriend struck viewed
the investigation into Trump Russia
collusion that was the insurance policy
that we knew they talked about and they
join the Russian investigation in order
to build a case to impugn and
potentially impeach the duly elected new
President of the United States assuming
that all their work in
release of all of those lives and all of
that propaganda and the dossier they
disseminated to influence the American
people before the vote in 2016 only
problem here is there was collusion but
it wasn't Trump Russia collusion
according to page the FBI had absolutely
no evidence after they started an
investigation after exonerating Hillary
this investigation began in July of 2016
Trump Russia collusion by the way they
went all the way through May of the next
year they found no evidence this is
before Bob mullah was ever appointed
they found nothing and here we are six
hundred and sixty-five days later
into what is Muller's intensive
investigation still zero signs of
collusion you know Rand Paul said today
the president's been saying this should
never happen to an American president in
this country this is the biggest abuse
of power corruption scandal we've ever
seen that also the conclusion of the
house Intel committee Devon Nunez
committee no Russia collusion the
bipartisan Senate investigation the burr
hearings no Russia collusion and four
months some people they've been trying
to tell me no mullahs are good and
honorable and decent man he served his
country Semper Fi he's a Marine and
peccable integrity I have wondered from
day one why did Bob Muller staff this
political investigation with only
Democratic donors why would he ever hire
Hillary Clinton supporters and a former
Clinton lawyer and no Republicans you
know you gotta wonder if Muller has paid
attention to all of the abuse of power
and corruption we have exposed right
here on this show for two years I wonder
if he has this fidelity to truth and the
law you know soon we will all know the
answer to that but it's not a good sign
that Muller
you know appoints a guy like Andrew
Weissman remember Enron the accounting
case tens of thousands of people lost
their job this guy license to lie in
Sidney Powell's book withheld
exculpatory evidence that's Muller's pit
bull Andrew Weissman then he put four
Merrill executives in jail for a full
year
that was overturned by the fifth circuit
why would why would he ever be hired by
Muller and today the poem attic for case
liberals aren't going to be happy unless
Paul Manafort dies in jail he was
sentenced to more prison time for the
second case that he had been involved in
none of them we now have two cases
nothing to do with collusion whatsoever
here's his attorney earlier today listen
to them
nice little protesters and resistance in
the background judge Jackson conceded
that there was absolutely no evidence of
any Russian collusion in this case so
that makes two courts two courts
overruled no evidence we should know the
judge in the mana four case is pushing
back saying the Russia investigation is
not yet over okay
but tonight but we have two
congressional delegations over if you
want to know the best sign that Muller
is not going to find any Russia
collusion then look no further than the
Cowardly shift himself Adam Schiff today
busy on his favorite conspiracy based
network MSNBC shifting the narrative
squirming when asked a simple question
about his previous grandiose claims that
he had evidence of collusion take a look
at my pal my friend who uses my name to
raise money here's the cowardly Schiff
had all along and and beginning the two
years ago as you point out until the
present date is there is ample evidence
of collusion but whether that evidence
amounts to proof beyond a reasonable
doubt a criminal conspiracy we would
have to wait for Bob Muller to determine
that is still very much my view the best
evidence of the the president's
complicity as a general matter is the
fact that he has been so deceptive about
all of these contacts time after time ah
now the Cowardly ship is actually trying
to shift the conversation away from
collusion take a look at this
if there's insufficient evidence in the
Muller report and we're not able to
produce sufficient evidence in our own
investigation that ends the inquiry
there may be grounds for removal from
office or there may be grounds for
indictment after he leaves office that
the Congress discovers one of the issues
that we're looking at which the mall
report may not cover is whether the
Russians were laundering money through
the Trump Organization our predominant
concern in my committee is was this
president is this president compromised
by a foreign power oh right so if
there's no collusion his committee is
now going to spend we've been three
years in this this started in July of
2016
they'll just keep investigating Trump
until the end of time now we're going to
be investigating what Trump did in
nursery school before this is said and
done and what hoping to find anything
their rage their hatred is beyond the
pale this is dangerous to the country
what they have done this is an abuse of
power and it will be exposed